الله الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره الرقميه اهلا وسهلا بكم رغم
التحذيرات الامريكيه من تاجيج التوتر خلال
رمضان اسرائيل تواصل التصعيد وتقتل الشاب
الفلسطينيه امير ابو خديجه في عمليه
مشتركه للجيش والشباك وتعتقل اخرين خلال
اقتحامها قريه عزبه شوفه شرقيه طولكرم كما
شنت حمله اعتقالات في مناطق اخرى بالضفه
الغربيه واشنطن تعتزم نقله مقاتلات حديثه
من الشرق الاوسط الى اوروبا واسيا وتقول
ان الخطوه لردع موسكو وبيجين ولمين العام
يشدد على ضروره الاستعداد لدعم اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه لفتره طويله بينما حضرت موسكو من
تداعيات ذلك وقالت انه يزيد من خطر اندلاع
حرب نوويه مدن فرنسيه تشهد اشتباكات بين
الشرطه والمحتجين الرافدين لرفع سن
التقاعد وسط تعبئه امنيه واسعه واضرابات
شامله في قطاعات عده واطلقت النقابات على
حشد اليوم اسم الخميس الاسود رفضا للقانون
الذي مررته الحكومه دون تصويت
برلماني للمره الاولى شوارع منطقه ويست
اند في لندن تضيء بسنه رمضان في حفل حضره
عمده المدينه الصادق خان وتميزت الزينه
باضواء على شكل اهله ونجوم وفوانيس رمضان
التقليديه تتوسطها عباره رمضان سعيد الى
اللقاء